[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه مع العيال اختيار السهلوها بابرز
العمل
توافق امريكيه المانيا على ارسال الدبابات
الى اوكرانيا وبرلين تسمح لبولندا باعاده
تصدير دبابات ليوبار للكياس
عقوبه امريكيه جديده تطلق كيانات تسهل
تمويل ميليشيا حزب الله عبر مراكز صيرفه
براسها على لبنان بعد توجيه قاده تحقيق
بانفجار مرفا بيروت اتهامات للنائب العام
وثلاثه قضاه
افغانستان بعد منع طالبان اكثر من مليون
فتاه من المدارس والجامعه
[موسيقى]
ازمه الدبابات الغربيه الى اوكرانيا يبدو
انها فرشت برلين ووافقه بلومبرج سم تمنح
موافقتها لبولاندا على ارسال دبابات
ليوبار الى اكياف هذا الاسبوع ومن وارسو
وبرلين الى واشنطن حيث كشفت وصفه جونير
على ان الولايات المتحده تتجه الى ارسال
دبابات ابرامز الى اوكرانيا وقد يتم الامر
هذا الاسبوع مضيفه اي وصف الجنه
بارسال كل دوله لعدد صغير من الدبابات
لاوكرانيا قد تمت
[موسيقى]
بدله كبيره اذن احدثتها دبابات الالمانيه
هل تعطيها المانيا ام لا وهل تسمح لاخرين
بتصيلها هذا الاسرار الاوكراني اولا
والغربي ثانيا على تزويد اكياس بهذه
الدبابات اسبابهم متعدده لكن اهم هذه
الاسباب ان لا يعتبر ستشكل نقل نوعيه في
الحرب مع منحها القوات الاوكرانيه القدره
الهجوميه وليس فقط الدفاع وصد الهجمات
الروسيه فضلا عن السهوله اللوجستيه
المانيا انت جد نحو تسعه الاف قطعه من هذه
الدبابات منذ عام
1963 ويتم تصنيع النوع نفسه في ثلاث دول
اخرى بترخيص من المانيا وتستخدمها جيوش
احدى وعشرين دوله
تشيرت تقديرات مشاهدينا الحاليه الى وجود
نحو الفي دبابات ليوبار تو في اوروبا اكثر
من 423 دبابه منها مخزنه في المانيا وفقا
للمعهد الدولي للدراسات الاستراتيجيه
تركيا تملك 316 دبابه لوبان تليها بولندا
مع دبابتين واليونان مع مئه وثلاثون دبابه
اما سويسرا فتمتلك همم من دبابات ليبار
1434 او 30 دبابه وفي ما لا يزال الاخد
والرد متواصلا ابدا شركه المعدات العسكريه
همم
ماتور الالمانيه لتزويد اوكرانيا بمائه
وتسعه وثلاثين دبابه من طراز اذا لازمه
الامر اضافات انه يمكن للشركه تسليم 99
دبابه بحلول او مايو
واثنتين و20 دبابه اخرى بحلول نهايه العام
الحالي كما اكدت مشاهدينا الشركه
الالمانيه امكانيه ارسال 88 دبابه من طراز
ليوبار 1 دون تحديد الموعد حتى الساعه
[موسيقى]
تاويلات كثيره يحملها الموقف الالماني
الاخير بشان الدبابات اليو بارك حيث تلام
برلين على بطئ التعامل مع المازق رغم حاجه
اوكرانيا المتزايده لتمكين قدرتها
الهجوميه لكن ما هو السبب لهذا التردد
واشنطن بوست مشاهدينا اكدت ان المانيا
تعاني من صدمه الحرب العالميه الثانيه
مضيفه ان مزيج العار وذم اثر العقود بصناع
القرار الالمانيين وفق الصحيفه واوضحت ان
الحكومه لا تريد ان تستخدم الاسلحه
الالمانيه على الخطوط الاماميه في مناطق
الصراع ثقافه الحذر العسكري لبرلين او
المخاوف المتعلقه باحتمال استفزاز روسيا
وحصول تصعيد في النساء احدى الاسباب
المتداوله ايضا اسباب وصفها نائب وزير
الخارجيه الاوكراني بالواهيه وغير
المنطقيه هذا الحذر العسكري سمح لشخصيات
اوروبيه انتقدت سابقا وان فقدت ايضا الى
التوجه للصداره من الناحيه الاخلاقيه
كرئيس الوز البولندي مثلا الاخير ده عاشود
الى اتخاذ اجراء حازم مضيفا انه على
المانيا ان تقرر ان كانت تريد الوقوف على
الجبهه الخاطئه من التاريخ المفارقه هي ان
المانيا واحده من اكبر موردي الاسلحه
والمساعدات الى كياب بعد الولايات المتحده
منذ بدا الحرب
الالمان سريعا هذه المره لان الالماني
يتاخرون ويتهربون ويتصرفون بطريقه يصعب
فهمها يمكننا ان نرى بوضوح شديد انهم لا
يريدون مساعده اوكرانيا في الدفاع عن
نفسها على نطاق اوسع بالطبع سنه تقدم بطلب
لسداد فاتوره الدبابات الى الاتحاد
الاوروبي
تعويضنا عن هذه التكاليف وامل ان يحدث ذلك
شي ثانيه
مراسل العربيه وايضا تنضم الينا من بارلين
راغده بهناء مراسله العربيه سابدا معك بعد
قرار الولايات المتحده بارسال الدبابات
ابرامز الى اوكرانيا هل هي المساومه
الامريكيه الالمانيه لحاث المانيا على
ارسال دباباتها
نحن في عمليه سياسيه اكثر مما نحن في
عمليه عسكريه بخصوص الدبابات واقصد من ذلك
ان الالمان وباقي الاوروبيين وحتى
الاوكرانيين كانوا يريدونها ان يسمعوا من
الامريكيين التزما واضحا ليس فقط بالتسليح
بالدبابات انما بما مبدا تحرير الاراضي
الاكرانيه من القوات الروسيه وارسال
الدبابات هو الرمز الاساسي لعمليه التحرير
هذا ما شاهدناه خلال الساعه الماضيه هو
اولا بدا تسريب معلومات على ان الامريكيين
سوف يرسلونها دبابات ابرامز الى
الاوكرانيين هذا الامر سوف ياخذ اسابيع
وربما لا ياتي في وقته من اجل الهجوم الذي
يخطط له الكره خلال
المقبله لتحرير اراضيهم في المقابل هناك
معلومات اضافيه من المانيا والمروج من
بولندا حوالي 40 دبابه سوف يرسلونها الى
اوكرانيا
بهذه النقطه الامريكيين والمسؤولين
الرسميين كانوا يتحدثون عن ان لا جدوى
لارسال هذه الدبابات الى هناك وبانها عبء
لوجست على الاوكرانيين ما الذي دفع الى
تغيير الموقف الامريكي في الساعات الماضيه
اعتقد ان العمليه الدبلوماسيه بين الالمان
والاوكرانيين والامريكيين كان الهدف منها
هو تاكيد الالتزام الامريكي ان من حق
الاوكرانيين تحرير اراضيهم وربما نستطيع
القول ايضا من ضمن هذه الاراضي هي جزيره
القرب الكلام على ان الامريكيين ملتزمين
بارسال ابرامز ارسال دبابات هذا يعني ان
من حق الاوكرانيين ان يحرروا اراضيها وعلى
الغرب وبشكل خاص قال الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ان تدعمه في ذلك ايا كانت
النتائج والتهديدات الروسيه بالرد على ذلك
امام اسرار امريكي واوروبي بعدم السماح
لبوتين بتحقيق اي انتصار بالربيع المقبل
هذه الخطوه باعطاء الدبابات اليوم الى
اكياس تاتي ضمن ايطار
اولا دعيني اذكر ليال بانه على الارجح يوم
غد سيكون هناك اعلان رسمي لهذا القرار من
المستشار الالماني او لاف شولد هو مفترض
ان يتحدث في البندستاج الساعه 1:00 بعد
الظهر بتوقيت بالين لدى يعني الاعتقاد
الان بانه سيعلن عن هذه الخطوه غدا في
البرلمان يعني ظهر ظهرا في وقت بالين ولكن
بالفعل يعني الان هناك حتى من يتحدث في
المانيا عن انه هذا انتصار دبلوماسي نوعا
مال الالمان لانه يعني حتى المتحدث باسم
الحكومه قال عندما سئل قبل يومين عن
الشروط التي وضعتها المانيا على واشنطن ان
هي تشترت ان ترسل واشنطن الدباباتها اولا
كان رد بانه انا استعد كثيرا همم ان يكون
مستشار المانيا يضع شروط على الرئيس
الامريكي لذلك الان ويبدو انه هذا بالفعل
هكذا كانت المساومه وتحقق للالمان ما
كانوا يشترطون فيه على الامريكيين هناك من
يعتقد الان بانه هذا سيكون او يعتبر
ديبرومات ديبلوماسي بالنسبه لالمانيا
وتخاصه المستشار الالماني او لاف شونس
لانه همم حصل على مكان يريد عندما قال
بانه هو المانيا لم تذهب منفردا لن تقدم
مساعدات منفرده لان يبدو بانه هذا التحالف
لارسال الدبابات حتى اوسع من الولايات
المتحده همم
تقول بانه فرنسا حتى يعني في المفاوضات
التي او المشاورات التي كانت تجري في
الايام الماضيه كان هناك التزام ايضا من
فرنسا ترسل هي ايضا دباباتها لانه التزام
فرنسا ايضا لم يكن واضح لذلك بالفعل همم
يعني هذه المشاورات كلها وهذا الهدوء الذي
ابتسم به شغل
الانتقادات كثيره وسوء يعني تواصل ربما
ولكنه في النهايه يعني حصنه بنظره المانيا
من اي تهديد او اعتداء روسيا محترم هناك
نقطه ايضا همم تقول بان الخلاف ابعد من
موضوع الدبابات اليوم بين الدول الغربيه
والولايات المتحده وهو الدعم لكياف مع ما
يمثله من امكانيه ماده الصراع بين الناتو
وموسكو هل سيتم بحث او تم بحث هذه النقطه
وتبديد الهواجس بها
هذه كانت نقطه الخوف الرئيسيه لدى
المستشار الالماني وزير الدفاع الجديد
بويس سبيس تونس كرر هذه النقطه يكررها
يوميا وتسلمه منصبه يعني فقط قبل وبعد
ايام في الواقعه الخميس الماضي ولكنه
يوميا يقول بانه مهما قررنا يجب ان يكون
الا يكون هناك تدخل للنيته لدول الناتو في
هذه الحرب لذلك كان هذا التاني وهذا همم
يعني التريث في اتخاذ هذا القرار همم ولكن
الان وقد اتخذ هذا القرار كما ذكرت لانه
قرار اتخذ على صعيد اكثر من دوله ليست
المانيا همم يعني لم تعد المانيا هي
الوحيده التي تعتبر انها قدمت هذه
الدبابات الغربيه المتطوره الكيات هناك
نوع من التضامن الغربي وهذا التضامن كان
جزء اساسي ايضا من ما كانت بالين تحاول ان
توصله وكان هناك تهديد في الواقع في
الايام القليله الماضيه بانه هذا التضامن
بدا ربما يتلاش ولم يقعد لم تعدد ولا
الغربيه ملتزمه بالالتزام نفسه همم بكيا
ولكن المانيا تكرر بانها ملتزمه بدعم كياف
وعلى روسيا الا تفوز في هذه الحرب ولذلك
في النهايه يعني رات بانه عليها ان تتخذ
هذا القرار همم ولكن
اسمحي لي شكرا لك بدايتها رغده من برلين
وفيير غانم من واشنطن همم اسمحوا لي ان
انتقل الى همم واشنطن ولا المؤتمر الصحفي
للبنتاجون والحديث عن ارسال الدبابات الى
اوكرانيا
الحديث عن مسائل افتراضيه سوف نقوم
بتزويدكم بالمعلومات المؤكده فور على
الحصول عليها
سمعنا ان الجيش الاوكراني سوف يحصل على
الدبابات ابراميس هذه القضيه تكتيكيه
وسوف
احتياجاتها اللوجستيه
ونسعى لمراجعه الاعلانات التي تم اطلاقها
كما تعلمون
هو النظام المعقد ويصعب وصيانته بشده وهذا
ما ذكرناه في السابق واليوم وفي المستقبل
مره اخرى دون الدخول في اي مساله افتراضيه
في اي فتره نقوم بتزويد اوكرانيا باي نوع
من انواع الانظمه فنحن نزودها ايضا
بالتدريج من اجل الحفاظ على قدراتها في
تلك الاسلحه فهاد اذا ما كان لنا نعلن عن
اي انظمه جديده فسوف نقوم باظهار ذلك على
المال هل من المفيد ان نمنح دوله اسلحه لا
تستطيع صيانتها كذلك لن ادخل في تفاصيل
الافتراضيه فان تركيزنا كان ينصب على
مجموعه الاتصال الخاصه في اوكرانيا
الاسبوع الماضي وما هي احتياجاته اوكرانيا
من اجل ان يكون لها اثر فعال في ميدان
المعركه لكننا كنا واضحين وبسوره عامه من
خلال عملياتنا الاستراتيجيه وجهه نظرنا
سوف نستمر في اجراء مناقشه مع اوكرانيا
وشراءكنا حول
المتطلبات الدفاعيه الطويله الامد ومتوسطه
الامد لاوكرانيا سوف نستمر في هذه
المحدثان
ما الذي يتم اعداده
لمواجهه اي احتمالات قد تقوم به
الصين وما هي درجه الاستعداد للولايات
المتحده
لاي ظرف طارق او محتمل
اذا مشاهدينا استمعنا الى جانب من المؤتمر
الصحفي من البنتاجون الذي لم يجزم ارسال
الدبابات حتى الساعه طبعا لم يجب الصحفيين
على الاسئله المتعلقه بالهواجز اللوجستيه
وغيره التي كانت تعيق عمليه
الدبابات وركز طبعا على الناحيه السياسيه
وهي التسليح القصير والطويل الامد للاكران
بمواجهه الروس طبعا منع الروس من تحقيق اي
تقدم استراتيجي بهذه المعركه باكمال هذا
الملف ايضا تستمر الاقالات والاستقالات في
القياده الاخرانيه بعد اعلان الحكام
الاقليميين لكياف وصومي
او وزير تنميه المجتمع وتطوير الاقليم من
منصبهما وكان نائب وزير الدفاع الاوكرانيه
همم فالوف قدم الثقالته صباح اليوم وقبل
ساعات اقال زيريسكي جريلو تيموشينكو من
منصب نائب رئيس مكتبه دون توضيح الاسباب
هذا ولم تمضي ساعات حتى اقيل اوليكسي
سيمونيك نو
منصب نائب المدعي العام واكد مكتب المدعي
العام لاوكرانيا المعلومات المتعلقه
باقاله همم باقالته من منصبه بناء على
طلبه يذكر ان المستشار رئيس الديوان
الرئاسي الاوكراني اليكسي اريستوفيتش قدم
استقالته قبل ايام
في الوقت الذي تشتد فيه الحرب الروسيه
تشهد حكومه كيف اضطرابات المزلزله اقالات
واستقالات بسبب قضايا فساد ابرز القيادات
التي تمت اقالتهام رئيس مكتب الرئيس
الاكراني الذي كان مسؤولا عن مشاريع اعاده
الاعمار كما استقال نائب وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني بعد فضيحه فساد فتلاف كان
مسؤولا عن الخدمات اللوجستيه للجيش كذلك
تمت اقالته نائب المدعي العام الاوكراني
علي
خلفيه فضيحه رحلته باهظه الثمن الى
اسبانيا للاستجمام اثناء الحرب
الذي تمت اقالته من منصب نائب لوزير تنميه
المجتمعات والاقاليم والبنيه التحتيه فقد
احتجزه المكتب الوطني لمكافحه الفساد بسبب
اختلاس امواله من الميزانيه ويشطبه في
حصوله على رشوه كما اعلن وزير مجلس
الوزراء
حكام عسكريين لخمس مناطق اوكرانيه اشهد
معارك ضاريه مع روسيا حاليا ومن غير
الواضح حتى الان اسباب العقاله
وعلى ارض الميدان حيث المعارك كشف مسؤولون
امريكيون لسيانان الامريكيه ان رئيس
الروسيه في الاعتمير بوتن سيتخذ خطوه
كبيره خلال الاسابيع القادمه لاستعاده
زمام المبادره في الحرب مع اوكرانيا واضاف
المسؤولون الامريكيون ايضا ان رئيس الروسي
يخطط لتعبئه جديده تصل الى 200 الجندي
الروسيه وفي السياق ذكرت شبكه يعني انا
الرئيس
الاوكرانيسكي لا يريد التخلي عن باخمود
مضيفه في الوقت ذاتها ان الامريكيون اكدوا
للجانب الاوكراني ان اهميه بخمسه
استراتيجيه تعد اقل من مناطق الجنوب
منظومه دفاعا جوي وضعها الجيش الروسي
بالقرب من قصر فلاديمير بوتن المفضل وهو
ما يعني تزايد المخاوف
الروسيه من ان اوكرانيا قادره على استهداف
العمق الروسي التايمز البريطانيه نقلت عن
موقع
الروسيه المعارضه انه تم رصد نظام الدفاع
الجوي بانسار في قريه يسريفا بالقرب من
مقر اقامه بوتين بالقرب من بحيره
الدفاع الجوي هذه تحمي بوتن شخصيا وعائلته
من هجوم اوكراني محتمل والمعروف عن نظام
انه قادر على اسقاط الطائرات وصواريخ كروز
وطائرات بدون طيار والمروحيات كما تم
تركيب انظمه مماثله الاسبوع الماضي على
اسطح العديد من المباني الدفاعيه
والاداريه في وسطكم وكذلك بالقرب من مقر
اقامه بوتن الرسمي في نوفو اوغاريفو
اوغاريو القريب من العاص روسيه
اوامر القياده الروسيه الجديده لقواتها
بحلق الشعر واللحاء اثارت غضب المقاتلين
الشيشان ومرتزقه ذقنه حيث وصف الرئيس
الشيشاني رمضان قدره في الامر بالاستفزاز
المتعمد الذي يصرف الانتباه عن العمل
الحقيقي والقتال اما رئيس فاجنر
فتلقى الاوامر لمقاتليه بالحلاقه بسخريه
نموذجيه وحاثه قديره على مضاعفه طول حياته
قائلا ان رجله كانوا مشغولين للغايه
بالقتال ولم يجدوا وقتا للتوقف في صالونات
الحلاقه هذا وشككت صحف غربيه ان تكون
التعليمات الجديده موجهه للجنود الروس بل
وضعتها في خانه تقويد مجموعه واكدت ان
مقاطع الفيديو المنتشره من ساحات القتال
تظهر التزام القوه الروسيه بالزي العسكري
وحلق الشعر انما عناصر فاجنر ومعظمهم
مودهنون صادقون من ذوي اللوحه طويله
بدوره اكد نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي
بميترميداف ان خصوم روسيا يراقبون انتاج
الاسلحه في روسيا مشيرا الى انه لادا
روسيا ما يكفي من جميع انواع الاسلحه بعكس
من يدلي به خصوم وسكو على حده وصفه واوضح
مدفاف خلال زيارته مصنع كلاشنكوف انه سيتم
الحديث قريبا بشكل خاص عن انتاج انواع
الاسلحه الاكثر طلبا مؤكدا انه سيتم
التركيز على الطائرات المسيره المطلوبه
بشكل خاص في العمليه العسكريه الخاصه
نبقى مشاهدينا في الملف الاوكراني حيث قال
رئيس بيلاروسيا
الكساندرلوكشن كو ان اوكرانيا اقترحت
توقيع ما سماه ميثاق عدم اعتداء بينما
تواصل تدريب وتصليح المسلحين في محاوله
لزعزعه استقرار بيلاروسيا كما اوضح لوكيشن
كو ان بلاده كانت ستتعرض لخطر كبير في حال
عدم الصمود امام الاحتجاجات التي اعقبت
انتخابات عام 2020 فلنستمع لما قاله
اوكرانيا وعدم ارسال قواتنا الى هناك وهم
يعرضون التوقيع على ميثاق عدم اعتداء ولكن
من ناحيه اخرى فانهم يعدون هذا المزيج
المتفجر ويسلحونه
التاسعه مستمره فيها بعد قليل
التربيه والتعليم العربيه ترصد انتشار
الاميه بين 50 الف طفل في مخيمات عشوائيات
شمال سوريا
[موسيقى]
وتحويل الاموال لحزب الله كما قالت وزاره
الخزانه الامريكيه ان العقوبات فرضت على
اشخاص سهل وتمويل ميليشيا حزب الله عبر
مراكز الصرافه او الصرافه الا ان قرار ذكر
البنك المركزي خمسه مرات لاول مره منذ بدء
سلسله العقوبات التي طالت افرادا سهل
وتمويل ميليشيا حزب الله في الداخل
اللبناني ذكر ان هذه العقوبه تاتي
بالتزامن مع فرد واشنطن والاتحاد الاوروبي
مزيدا من العقوبات على ايران
العقوبات الغربيه لاسيوم الامريكيه منها
على ايران هي ليست وليده اليوم فهذه
العقوبات بداتها واشنطن منذ عام 1979 ثم
توالت الى انضمت اليها اوروبا ايضا وحتى
يومنا هذا لا تزال العقوبات تفرض على
طهران والتي بداتها اداره الرئيس جيمي
كارتر في نوفمبر 1979 بعد الستلاء طلاب
متشددين على السفاره الامريكيه في طهران
واحتجاز
رهائن واصدار وقتها كارت امرا تنفيذيا
بتجميد 8 مليارات دولار من الاصول
الايرانيه ثم جاء الرئيس
رونالدن حظر بيع الاسلحه لظهران عام
1983 مما في ذلك قطع الغيار العسكريه او
قطع الغيار العسكريه الامريكيه للجيش
اثناء الحرب الايرانيه العراقيه
وتسارعت مشاهدينا وتيره العقبات في يناير
عام 1984 بتصنيف ايران لراعيه للارهاب في
اعقاب استهداف سكنات مشات البحريه
الامريكيه في بيروت ليعود ريجن ويفرد حظرا
على السلع والخدمات الايرانيه واكملها من
بعده كلينتون في عام 1995 بدورها استكملت
اداره جورج بوش الابن مسيره العقوبات
الامريكيه ضد ايران الذي امر عام 2005
باستهداف العقوبات لافراد والكيانات التي
تزود ايران بالتكنولوجيا النوويه واسلحه
الدمار الشامل كما استهدفت ايضا عددا من
المؤسسات والبنوك الايرانيه
[موسيقى]
اما فتره باراك اوباما مشاهدين فقط مثلت
بدايه لمرحله العقوبات الشامله اذا وقع
اوباما في يوليو عام 2010 قانون العقوبات
الشامله ضد ايران والمحاسبه والتجريد من
الممتلكات ووسع هذا القانون بشكل كبير
العقوبات الشامله ضد ايران كما اضاف انواع
جديده من العقبات واوروبا ايضا اتبعت ذات
النهج في العقوبات وابرزها عام 2012 عند
موافق الاتحاد الاوروبي على حظر وردات
النفط الايراني مانعا طبعا شراء او نقل
البترول الايراني من اوروبا او المرور عبر
اوروبا حتى امتدت هذه العقوبات الى قطاع
التكنولوجيا والصناعات البتروكيماويه
والاصالات في مايو 2018 انها دونالد ترامب
مشاركه بلاده في خطه العمل الشامله
المشتركه للالتفاق النووي واصدر مشاهدينا
في اليوم نفسه تعليمات بالمشروع والشروع
في خطوات لاعاده فرض جميع العقوبات
الامريكيه التي تم رفعها او التنازل عنها
نتيجه طبعا للاتفاق النوويه الايراني
واضاف مزيدا من هذه العقوبات ثم اتت بعد
هذه العقوبات عقوبات امريكيه واوروبيه
مؤخرا نتيجه القمع الايراني للاحتجاجات
وانتاج سياسه الاعدامات بحق المتظاهرين
السلميين وهو ما زاد الامر سوءا لطهران
واذا ما جلست طبعا مستقبلا مع الغرب على
طاولات المفاوضات
[موسيقى]
وقفي ملف التظاهرات اكدت شبكه سينان
الامريكيه تراجع الرقم الاحتجاجات في
ايران بعد اربعه اشهر على انطلاقها وذلك
على خلفيه التزايد القمع ضد المتظاهرين
والسبعه ذات تصدع اراده النظام في ظل غياب
ما سمته الكتله الحرجه في الشوارع ورجحت
الشبكه الامريكيه ابتعاد الاشخاص الذين
تزيد اعمارهم عن 25 عاما عن المظاهرات ما
افقد
الاحتجاجاتا الى ان بقايا الانتفاضه
الشعبيه تلاشت بعد احكام الاعدام التي
اصدرها القضاء الايراني خلال الاسابيع
الاخيره وتعاد عمليات الاعدام تتويجا
لحمله قام عنيفه بشكل متزايد شملت قتل
المتظاهرين بالرصاص ولا اعتقالات الجماعيه
[موسيقى]
الى بيروت وبعد عام من الغياب عاده
التحقيقات في تفجير مرفا بيروت هذه المره
بمفاجاه اذا دعى المحقق العدل في القضيه
القاضي طارق بيطار على اربعه قضاه بينهم
النائب العام التمييزي في اجراء غير مسبوق
رفضته النيابه العامه التمييزيه وقد اثارت
خطوه البيطار غضب من عمل على استدعائهم
فرفض طبعا مدعي عام التمييز غسان عويدات
قرار البيطار واصفا اياه بالقاضي المكفوفه
يده
[موسيقى]
هو القاضي الذي قفل يده اكثر من 40 مره
عاد بعد غياب تخطى العام اشهر انتفاضته
القضائيه بوجه محاولات جماعيه لعرقلتي سير
العداله
طارق البيطار لنفسه استئناف وتحقيقات
انفجار المرفق قبل
بالصدفه
عويدات قرار استدعائه رسميا ضمن لائحه من
ثمانيه اشخاص على راسها ايضا المدير العام
للامن العام اللواء عباس ابراهيم الذي منع
البيطار من استدعائه سابقا
قرار اثلج قلوب اهالي الضحايا بعد ان بحث
حناجرهم مطالبين باستئناف التحقيقات
راي قانوني مخالف ممكن مراجعه المحاكم
المختصه مثل ما حتى هو باراره اشار لهذا
الموضوع انه اليوم المجلس العدلي عنده
الصلاحيه في ابطال او باعتبار ايا تحقيقات
غربنا»
لليوم عم تتحرك اكثر هي موقف النيابه
العامه من مساله خلقت السبيل بحق
الموقوفين بالملف اليوم في خمس اخلاء سبيل
لا يزيل اليوم مصير تنفيذه او عدم تنفيذه
مجهول
على اثرها ازدحمت ارجوك تقصر العدل بحسب
المعلومات بمبتدينا من المده عليهم وعلي
حسن خليل ويوسف
الوزراء المحسوبين على حزب الله وحركتي
امل
ووصلنا خوف النيه وشارعا شبيه بشارع
السابع من ايار ومخاطر قد يتعرض لها
البيطار تحدثت اوساطه قاضي التحقيق عن
قيامه بما يمليه عليه ضميره وان ما يخشى
عليه فقط هو مسار التحقيقات
تعمل
المنطقه
المستمر بالقضاء يتركب الشارع اللبناني
ردود فعل من استدعائهم القضاء في قضيه
تسارعت احداثها بعد تجميدها لاكثر من عام
وصى مطالبات دوليه بتحقيقا عادل وشفاف غن
ويتيم العربيه بيروت
تحقيقات ومرفق بيروت لم تثمر بعد واهالي
الضحايا المئتين واربعه عشر لا يزالون
بانتظار ما يبردوا قلوبهم فما هي مشاهدينا
مراحل التحقيق على مدى اكثر من عامين في
الرابع عشر من اغسطس 2020 عين مجلس القضاء
الاعلى قاضي التحقيق العسكري فادي صوان
لقياده التحقيق في انفجار مرفا بيروت بين
منتصف اغسطس وبدايه سبتمبر امر صوان
باعتقال 25 من موظفين الميناء ومسؤولين من
رتب متوسطه الى منخفضه في نوفمبر من العام
نفسه طالب البرلمان بالتحقيق مع اثناء 10
وزيرا حاليا وسابقا لدورهم في الانفجار ثم
حالتهم لمحكمه خاصه لكن وقتها رئيس مجلس
النواب نبيه بري رفض ذلك بعدها بالشهر
اتهم صوان رئيس الوزراء المؤقت حينها حسان
دياب ووزير الماليه سابق علي حسن خليل
وزيري الاشغال العامه
سابق غازي زعيتر ويوسف فنيانوس بالاهمال
زعيتر وخليل رفعاه دعوى قضائيه امام محكمه
النقض لابعاد صوان عن التحقيق بحجه انه لم
يكن محايده ولا موضوعا واوقف صوان
تحقيقاته بالفعل وقبل ذلك نعود مشاهدينا
الى المشاهد الاولى من التفجير الماساوي
مرفق بيروت فنوته
[موسيقى]
اكمل المسار القضائي في فبراير 2021 امرت
محكمه النقض بابعاد صوان من التحقيقات
واستبدل بالقاضي طارق البيطار رئيس محكمه
جنايات بيروت في يوليو 2021 طلب بطار من
البرلمان رفع الحصانه عن النواب والوزراء
السابقين خليل وزعيه وزير الداخليه السابق
نهاد المشنوق لكنه لم يلقى السجابه وطلب
بطار الاذن باستجواب رئيسيه امن الدوله
والامن العام وارجع الطلباته طبعا الرفض
والتجاهل في الثامن والعشرين من يوليو
2000 21 رفعت نقابته المحامين في كل من
بيروت وطرابلس الحسنات عن زعيتر وخليل
وفنيانوس لكنهم ضلوا يتمتعون بالحصانه
النيابيه القاضي البيطار تجاهل 40 دعوه
طالبت بتنحيه واستئناف عمله بعد توقف دام
ثلاثه عشر شهرا
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من بيروت غسان حصباني
نائب رئيس الحكومه السابق والنائب في
البرلمان الحالي استاذ غسان يعني امام
سابقه قضائيه لم يشهدها بتاريخ لبنان لم
يشهد على هكذا سابقا اسنادا لمستند عليه
المحقق العدل بان لا سلطه قضائيه تعلو على
السلطه الاداريه هل نحن امام صراع قضائي
وتصعيد قضائي بعد زياره المحققين
الفرنسيين الى بيروت
ليش كان هذه الخطوه متقدمه جدا وهي باتجاه
استكمال التحقيق الذي يطالب به اهالي
المتضررين والكثير من اللبنانيين وهم
بانتظار نتائجه اما من ناحيه اخلاء سبيل
بعض الموقفين الذين قد يثبت عدم ارتباطهم
بالموضوع او يعني اذاناتهم او من خلال
المقاضات
والادعاء على اخرين همم لذلك هي خطوه
متقدمه طبعا خطوه غير مسبوقه بطبيعتها
وبحجها لان الراي العام اللبناني اعتاد
على يعني تفادي كشف الحقائق همم وقمع همم
التحقيقات لكن هناك ايضا همم اراء مختلفه
داخل القضاء خاصه ان هناك يعني همم فتح
ملفات لقضاء ايضا اضافه لانني همم اشخاص
في الطبقه السياسيه
ده الاجتهاد القانوني والدستوري هناك
تساؤلات عن تداعيات هذه الخطوه وانا
احتماليه صدور قرار ضمن سريع هل هناك
انعكاسات امنيه اجتماعيه سياسيه همم ممكن
ان نترقبها بالايام والاسابيع المقبله
يعني طبعا هناك الاعتراضات دائمه
والمحاولات الدائمه لكافيه المحقق العدلي
او تعديلي او تغييره كما راينا في السابق
او حتى يعني همم
استبداله بمحقق رديف همم يبدو ان كله لم
تنجح حتى الان همم قد يكون هناك همم
عراقيل اضافيه اما ضمن التفسيرات
الدستوريه والقانونيه في الممارسه وغيرها
همم لكن يعني لا اعتقد ان تداعيات ستكون
اكبر بكثير من هذا الحجم اضافه الى ان هذا
المسار قد يؤدي لاحقا الى همم يعني همم
رفع همم اتهامات وقرارات اتهاميه وواضحه
بحق بعض الاشخاص بعد اتخاذ واستكمال هذه
الخطوه مما يقرب المسار اكثر الى كشف
الحقيقه همم
يعني انهاء هذا همم الجنود الامريكان يشو
بالتحقيق
الثاني يعني هناك تسريبات قضائيه وسياسيه
بالساعات الماضيه عن
تلميح بعقوبات ضد رئيس مجلس القضاء الاعلى
اتحدث عن الوفد القضائي الفرنسي وعن دعم
سياسي لهذه الخطوه بالتصعيد بواجه كل من
هو يعني افلت من التحقيق بالساعات الماضيه
هل فيها شيء من الصحه
ولا اعتقد ان هناك تدخل مباشر من المحققين
او ارتباط مباشر بهذا الحدث قد يكون هناك
يعني ارتباط غير مباشر والرئيل جدا ولكن
لا اعتقد انه بهذه الشده لكن ايضا نحن
طلبنا همم لجنه حقائق من همم يعني الامم
المتحده حتى بهذا الموضوع اقله لكشف
الحقائق الحقائق المرتبطه بهذا الانفجار
الضخم الذي ليس فقط على مستوردنها ولكن
على مستوى العالم وانفجار كبير وحدثون همم
سيء جدا همم يعني قتل الكثير من
اللبنانيين ودمر جزءا كبيرا من العاصمه لا
يجوز الاستغفاف به هناك اهتمام دولي به لا
شك ولكن ايضا القضاء اللبناني اختار ان
يكون مسار محلي نحن نقول ان المسار المحلي
عليه ان يكون مدعوما ايضا بمسارات دوليه
نسبه لحجم هذه
الحدث طبعا
وكشفا ان للحقائق اقله للوصول الى معرفه
الحقيقه
ويعني ازاله اي التباس حولها وصولا الى
المحاسبه في وقت اللحم طبعا يعني العداله
لاهالي ضحايا هي مطلب الجميع اليوم شكرا
لك دكتور غسان حصباني نائب رئيس الحكومه
السابق والنائب في البرلمان الحالي على
هذه المداخله من بيروت
[موسيقى]
اعدد فرنسا 15 امراه واثنين وثلاثين طفلا
كانوا معتقلين في مخيمات يحتجز فيها عناصر
متطرفه تابعه لداعش شمال شرقي سوريا هذا
ويعاني نحو 50,000 طفل من الاميه و20,000
عائله تعاني من الجوع في مخيمات عشوائيه
باطراف مدينه الرقه
المسؤولون في مبنى الخارجيه الفرنسيه هنا
عملوا على ترتيبات نقل 32 طفلا وخمسه عشره
امراه من عائله الفرنسيين لداعش
والمحتجزين في مخيمات شرق سوريا جاء ذلك
بعد ان قررت باريس التخلي عن سياستها في
دراستك كل حاله على حدا جرى انتقادات من
عائلات عناصر داعش الفرنسيين والامم
المتحده هذه الخطوه تاتي بعد ثلاثه ايام
من اتهام لجنه ملاحظه التعذيب في الامم
المتحده لفرنسا بالتقصير في حمايتها هؤلاء
النساء والاطفال ورغم دفاع باريس عن
موقفها السابق الرافض لعودتهم بشكل جماعي
تحت مبرر ان معاهده التعذيب لا تفرض على
اي بلد حمايه مواطنين في اراد ليست تحت
سلطته القضائيه الا انهارده خط وقبيله
استقبالهم من باريس زينه عادي
[موسيقى]
شمس المعاناه تؤذن بصباح جديد صباح يبدا
مختلفه عن اي مكان اخر في العالم
يبداوا نحو 72 الف سوري نهارهم هكذا الحطب
لتدفئه الصغار وغسل الملابس على الفطور لا
يتوفر غالبا سوى الخبز
احنا عجايز ختايره بها الوساخه وهز زباله
والله يا اخوي وحق الخبز ما نلقاه شكل
التفاحه نسيناها شكلها برتقاله نسيناها
قرن الموز معدن نعرف شلون شكله ريحه اللحم
والله العظيم ما تشوفوا
اليها الاطفال
من منهم يستطيع ان يقرا هذه الجمله في حدا
يعرف في قرار شو كاتب هنا
انتم ولا واحد منكم فايت على المدرسه
ليش ما فتوه على المدرسه ليش ما رحتوا على
المدرسه
وهو ما يثير مخاوف الاداره المدنيه للرقه
التي تواجه قائمه طويله من المشاكل التي
تبدا بالجوع ولا تنتهي باميه الاطفال
موجوده ضمن هذه المدينه
وعلى التحالف الدولي ومنظمات
الدوليه التفاعل مع هذه
الخطه اللي نستطيع القضاء على هذه المشكله
وتخطط الاداره الذاتيه منذ سنوات لجمع
العشوائيات في ثلاث نقاط رئيسيه ودفع
المنظمات الانسانيه للعمل فيها
توقفت كثيرا وخطت قليله لضعف الامكانيات
كل الحلول التي وضعت هنا لحل مشكله
المخيمات العشوائيه ومنحها صفه المخيمات
المنظمه فشلت حتى الان الاميه تتفشى كما
الفقر والجوع والقهر والمرض
لا يمكن لحاطه بها في خبر او تقرير من احد
المخيمات العشوائيه في مدينه الرقه شمال
شرق سوريا
التاسعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
مسلح يفتح النار داخل متجر بولايه واشنطن
ويقتل ثلاثه اشخاص
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد تظاهرات نساء افغانيات
ضد طالبان اليوم بالتزامني مع اليوم
العالمي للتعليم والذي وافق في الرابع
والعشرين من يناير من كل عام ورفضت
المتظاهرات الحظر التعليميه عليهن الذي
تفرضه طالبان في افغانستان واكدنا على ان
حركه طالبان حرمت الفتيات من حق التعليم
والمعرفه تذكر ان اليوم الدولي للتعليم
هذا العام خصصته يناسكو لافغانستان تضامن
مع النساء اللواتي حرمنا من التعليم
كما دعاء امين عام الامم المتحده انطونيو
جوتيرش في اليوم العالمي للتعليم طالبان
الى التراجع عن قرارها بشان تقييد ومنع
التعليم للفتيات في افغانستان وقال بوترش
ان الوقت قد حالي لانهاء كافه القوانين
التي تعيق الوصول الى تعليم بجهه اشار
مكتب الامم المتحده لتنسيق الشؤون
الانسانيه في افغانستان الى ان حركه
طالبان منعت اكثر من مليون فتاه من
الالتحاق بالمدارس والجامعه
[موسيقى]
مشاركه
من قرار طالبان منعهم من التعليم انتشرت
عبر وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
بالجامعه والمدارس
طالبان لا
لحكومه طالبان
هذه المقاطع تزامنت مع اليوم العالمي
للتعليم الذي خصصته اليونسكو هذا العام
لدعم الافغانيات في حقهن بالتعليم حيث طلب
الامين العام للامم المتحده الحركه
بالعدول عن قراراتها التي منعت اكثر من
مليون فتاه من الالتحاق بالمدارس واكثر من
مئه الف طالبه من ارتياد الجامعات ومنع
مئات الالاف منهن من العمل
امر قامه العديد من الافغانيات بالتظاهر
ضده في عده مناسبات وفي مواجهه تعنت
قيادات طالبان في قندهار ضاعفه الامم
المتحده جهودها لاقناع الحركه بالتراجع عن
قراراتها عبر وفود الامميه وانسانيه حيث
جمدت العديد من المنظمات الاغاثيه نشاطها
في افغانستان بعد قرار الحركه منع
الافغانيه من العمل في هذه المنظمات
الامر الذي يعرض الملايين من الافغاني
لخطر المجاعه
انا اصلا ماسي العربيه
كيف تصفون هذه الخطوه الرمزيه التي قامت
بها من الامم المتحده وكيف يمكن تطوير
يعني الالتزامات الدوليه لتصبح شيء ملموس
على الارض
اليوم احتفل العالم باليوم العالمي
للتعليم
النساء
اللي يوجد في هذا همم رساله من قبل الامم
المتحده ان همم افغانستان همم بحاجه اليها
من الى بحاجه الى تعليم النساء الا من
حاجاته الى تعليم الرجاء لان النساء يعني
بجانب كون ال- مسؤوليات اجتماعيه على ثقهن
هنا ايضا المسؤوليات عن همم تربيه وانشاء
الجيل القادم يعني
والامهات الاميات لا لا يقدرن على انشاء
جيل ايه يعني ذات اقول اقول
سليمه وذات افكار عاليه مثقفه همم فهذا
شيء الثاني واما الشيء الثالث ان يعني
حكومه طالبان او حكومه سلطه الامر
الواقعيه في افغانستان نحن راينا انها
فعلا فشل في تمهيد الطريق من اجل اتاحه
المجال تعليم النساء في افغانستان همم
وهذا لا يصح نعم
يتم هذا على حساب يعني على حساب نظام
التعليم للنساء اليوم 80% من الفتيات
بعمر التعليم وبالتالي نحن نتحدث عن اثنين
فاصله خمسه مليون فتاه
محرومين اليوم من التعليم هل الحلول
البديله التي تعمل عليها الامم المتحده
همم تلاقي طموحات الفتيات او تستطيع تدعم
التعليم هناك
طبعا يعني
المناشدات الدوليه
وايضا الضغوط السياسيه همم
لنراه اليوم على حكومه الطالبان وكذلك
نضيف الى ذلك
اعتراضات مدنيه ومحاولات داخليه حتى من
صفوف الطالبان نفسهم يعني واا محاولات من
قبل النساء افغانستان همم
خلال مقابلات محادثات ما شخصيات كبار يعني
شخصيات داخل افغانستان لقيناء قاده
الطالبان على الغاء القرار بمنع الفتيات
من التعليم هذا لها اثر يعني سيكون لها
اثر في المستقبل ان شاء الله قناه نامل في
ذلك اليوم يعني هناك بعض المبادرات التي
تقوم بها الامم المتحده بالشراكه مع
المنظمات الدوليه كالتعليم عن بعد عبر
الانترنت ك- التعليم بمدارس سريه وغير هل
يعني تساعد اليوم الفتيات في افغانستان
باختصار لو سمحت
نعم هذا اقدام لها عام لها يعني تاثير
ايجابي على كما قلت قبل بان هذا الاقدام
لها هذا العمل لها تاثير ايجابي على نفسيه
طالبات قبل اي شيء لانها اعمل يعني بطبع
امل قليل وعمل محدود يعني
عمل محدد هو صغير ومؤقت ولا يمكن ان نقول
له انها يعني الحل الدائم لمشكله تعليم
البنات في افغانستان لكن طبعا له تاثيراته
له تاثيره ايجابيه يعني شكرا لك يا استاذه
زينب حكيمي الاستاذه الجامعيه وناشطه في
مجال حقوق المراه على هذه الرساله
اليوم هو اليوم الدولي للتعليم في الوقت
الذي اغلقت الحكومه المراكز التعليميه
امام الفتيات لا نريد التعليم الطالبان لا
لحكومه طالبان
[موسيقى]
لقي مالا يقول عن ثلاثه اشخاص مصران اثناء
اطلاق نار خلال الليل في المتجر بولايه
واشنطن وحسب ما افاد قائد شرطه المدينه
باطلاق النار لا يزال طليقا ولا تعرف
الشرطه دوافع فعلتها حتى الساعه
اودينا اربعه عناصر من ميليشيا حراس القسم
اليمنيه المتطرفه بالتمرد لدورهم في
الهجوم على مقر الكونجرس الامريكي في
واشنطن وذلك في ختام ثاني محاكمه تجرى
بهذه الحادثه ياتي ذلك بعد ايقاف اكثر من
950 من انصار الرئيس الجمهوريه السابق
دونالد ترامب منذ الهجوم على الكابتل في
واشنطن في السادس من يناير 2021 ومجهت
اليهم التهم رسميا لزرعهم الفوضى في مقر
الديمقراطيه الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
قال رئيس الوزراء السويدي انه لا يوجد ما
هو اهم لامن السويد القومي من الانضمام
واكد انه يريد العوده للحوار مع تركيا
اجتماعا ثلاثيه مع السويد وفنلندا بشان
الانضمام للنيترو دون تحديد موعد بديل هذا
وقال وزير خارجيه في لندن على فنلندا ان
تدرس احتمال الانضمام الى الحلف بدون
السويد كما اكد انا فنلندا قد تعيد النظر
بامر الانضمام الى الناتو اذا تاخر طلب
السويد
[موسيقى]
الى نيوزيلندا مشاهدينا وفي اخر ظهور لها
كرئيسه وزراء قالت رئيسه الوزراء ان اكثر
ما ستفتقده هو الناس واهم الناس لانهم
كانوا مصدر المتعه في عملها على حد وصفها
وكانت رئيسه الوزراء التي تعتبر رمزا
عالميا لليسار قد صدمت مؤيديها باعلامها
الاستقاله من رئاسه الوزراء بعد اكثر من
خمس سنوات
لديها القدره على الاستمرار وسوط نواب حزب
العمال بالاجماع الاحد الماضي لاختيار
كريسكن خلفا لها ومن المقرر ان يؤدي
اليمين الاربعاء
[موسيقى]
الى الجزائر وفي ظاهره جويه نادره شهدت
ولايه ولايه جزائريه صباح الثلاثاء تساقطا
كثيفا للثلوج خاصه في منطقه بنيون ونيف
حيث كانت اخر مره تساقطت بها الثلوج سنه
2012 وغطت الثلوج الكثبان الرمليه
والشوارع في مشهد طبيعي نادر في هذه
المنطقه الصحراويه بعد موجه البرد التي
اجتاحت الولايه
[موسيقى]
بانتظار بس حفل جوائز الافكار في الثانيه
عشر من مارس المقبل كشفت اكاديميه علوم
وفنون الصور المتحركه المانحه لجوائز
الاوسكار عن الافلام المرشحه لجوائز
الاوسكار في فئه افضل فيلم لعام 2022
وابرزها في الماء افاتار وتوب جان للممثل
توم كروز
ختام التاسع
رغم عدم تاكيد البنتاجون حديث عن توافق
امريكي المانيه على ارسال دبابات
لاوكرانيا وبرلين تسمح اخيرا بارسال
تمويل ميليشيا حزب الله عبر مراكز قصيره
يا شعبان
قالوا ناسكم تخصص اليوم العالمي للتعليم
الفتيات افغانستان بعد منع طالبان لاكثر
من مليون فتاه من المدارس والجامعه